so welcome to the UVM extension new
farmer project webinar land access for
beginning farmers part 2 i'm jessie
schmidt i help coordinate the new farmer
project for you vm extension the focus
of this presentation is that many
variables that should be considered when
assessing farms land and farm
infrastructure for a rental or purchase
our presenters this evening are Ben
Waterman and Cathy roof Ben Waterman
coordinates the land access program at
the center for sustainable agriculture
and provides free consulting services to
landowners and farmers on natural
resource management farm Enterprise
startup foreign land conservation land
use regulations and farm tenure Ben
works closely with UVM extensions new
farmer project to develop our
educational resources for small farmers
and the startup stages of their business
Cathy roof is co-director for of land
for good New England nonprofit that
specializes in working land access our
sons last all right specializes in
working on land access and farm
succession she's worked for over two
decades on beginning farmer and farm
land tenure issues she also coordinates
the Northeast sustainable agriculture
working group so welcome and and Cathy
thanks Jesse and I welcome everyone to
part two of this webinar series Kathy
and I will be presenting although I have
the majority of time on the floor for
this part of the webinar series that
kathy will chime in when as needed or or
whenever you feel the need Kathy feel
free to chime in before we start just
curious again where is everyone from if
you could enter into the chat box just
just the state that you are from once
again that would be really helpful give
everyone a chance to practice using the
chat box there
okay can everyone hear me no one no
one's entering anything into the chat
box here so use this smiley face if you
can hear me great so let's let's try it
this way then use the smiley face again
if you're if you're farming in Vermont
or if you live in Vermont and how about
New Hampshire
New York
massachusetts couple people Rhode Island
Connecticut has anyone from anywhere
else where are you from melville
okay well thanks it's it's good to know
where people are coming from which will
try to give it seems like for the most
part we're all from the Northeast region
or New England so we'll try to relay
some information that's pertinent to
everyone here feel free to stop me at
any time or into your questions in the
chat box as our slides go on we'd love
to to try to cater this presentation to
to your needs into your questions so
again feel free to use the chat box and
if we can't get to your questions
immediately we will try to address them
as the webinar goes on so a brief recap
of part 1 of the webinar series a couple
weeks ago Katherine I went over basic
land access concepts and we went through
a wide variety of options that farmers
can pursue to acquire land and gain
access to it and one main take-home
message from that part 1 of the webinar
series was that you don't have to own
land to acquire it and various lease
arrangements and other scenarios can
enable you to get onto the land with
without necessarily purchasing it and
last webinar we also went through the
types of leases and what what is
incorporated in a typical lease and we
also touched on a little bit about where
to search for fun land but tonight's
webinar will center around readiness
concepts and planning and preparing for
farm tenure and we'll also go through
assessing particular parcels the tools
and resources you can use to learn much
more about a particular site that you
are interested in
so to get ready does everyone recognized
the group on the right here this is this
is the temptations initially I was going
to come out and sing their song get
ready but as Cathy do you want to go
ahead and sing that song to get things
going here and get ready no and I guess
there's only three of us with the
microphone Jessie would you like to sing
get ready all right well let me try all
right here get ready cause here I come
Twitter Leedy and Twitter lead um look
out baby cause here I come how was it
I'm job
hey just try to get everyone's attention
here so I you can either clap or use
some of these icons if you like the
little song there so getting ready for
farm land tenure involves various things
that we're going to be discussing in the
next half hour or 45 minutes before we
get into the principles involved in
assessing particular properties so so
briefly we're going to be talking about
determining whether or not land is your
limiting factor we talked about
evaluating your needs versus you wants
integrating family values considering
ownership costs this this is a big one
right here it's a lot of times beginning
farmers underestimate how much it's
going to cost them actually to own land
or what are the costs involved in
actually leasing land they needless to
say I have enormous implications for
moving your farm business forward we're
going to go through a farm land purchase
and leasing considerations that can be
integrated into a business plan and
we'll also look at if you're looking to
acquire a farm through purchase we'll
look at how to prepare for approaching a
loan officer or obtaining a loan to do
so
so as land acquisition right for you um
you know what what really is your your
limiting factor in in in moving your
farm business forward or your your your
family life forward a lot of times there
are other things that might be holding a
new farmer back and and land might not
be on the top of that list so there are
other typical challenges that are
associated with that are that are the
typical barriers to starting up a farm
it could be lack of production knowledge
and skills it could be you don't have
markets that are developed yet you know
the huge one is there's not enough time
it's that's not talked about a lot but
the truth is for a lot of beginning
farmers there's just no time to work on
the farm because they have to oftentimes
work off the farm so it is is addressing
the land axis very going to be the first
thing that's most important to moving
your business forward and that's that's
the main question you know what so if if
it's if lack of production knowledge and
skills is the main barrier then maybe
before looking into acquiring land it's
best to look into the various
apprenticeship programs or even get a
job on a farm so you really hit the
ground running once you do acquire land
capital there's there's not there's not
as much as a fine line between lack of
capital lack of land that kind of go
hand in hand but oftentimes you can get
financing or capital to start a business
that's that's not centered on the land
piece you don't need 40 or 100 or 200
acres of land necessarily to start a
business with making productive use of
your assets and capital
and it's needless to say it's really
important to filter out your needs from
your wants now this is assuming that
that you're that you have already
identified that you're limiting factor
is indeed land access or at least it's a
major limiting limiting factor for you
now what what type of land or what what
type of tenure situation or scenario is
going to fulfill your needs in terms of
let of what what is most limiting to you
what type of land you need in other
words so this is otherwise known as the
minimalist strategy if you're really
focusing on what it is you need out of a
property and it's kind of
counterintuitive but if you can sort of
filter down what you actually need out
of a property or out of a farm tender
situation it actually opens up more
10-year opportunities that's really a
counterintuitive but the fact is that
the real viable opportunities are going
to open up to you when they're more
based on what you need and when and
they're more based on the scale of
business that you're at so north other
other words there be more realistic
opportunities available for you if you
can really focus on what you need out of
a property versus what you want everyone
wants the the farm property that's on
the cover of all the magazines but could
you are you going to be able to manage
that type of property when you get onto
it even in the long term is it something
that you could grow into those are
questions that are worth asking from the
get-go in terms of garner garnering
support for your farm operation you
might be reaching out to community
members for financing you might be
approaching loan offers once you do get
access to land you might be reaching out
to two loan officers to extend you a
loan and my experience has been that
people are much more willing to support
an operation that they know is making
more
less than you know they have too much to
handle so that's something to keep in
mind and then of course in terms of
protecting yourself from unexpected
costs they're huge costs associated with
owning and in leasing more more land
that you need more land that you can use
productively so in order to protect
yourself from that risk it's good to
really focus on what what you need this
is a checklist that's available in
holding ground which kathy had a huge
part in in writing this is a guide to
northeast prime land tenure and
stewardship it's currently available for
sale at the New England small farms
Institute bookstore and this page is
page 31 out of that text i highly
recommend everyone getting ahold of this
if they are serious about acquiring land
either through lease or purchase or
alternative other alternative means it
goes through all sorts of scenarios all
different options in in acquiring land
and this is a great checklist that can
guide you through some of the
considerations that you can make and I
apologize to everyone because the the
text might not be readable here but the
way Kathy's laid it out here is that
you're really you're looking at each of
these factors whether it be location
land-based climate infrastructure
housing or the history of the land and
you're you're assessing for your
particular situation whether or not each
of these factors is necessary to your to
your farm operation or your family
ambitions whether or not they're these
factors are desirable or optional so you
know it's really it's sometimes it's
tough to go to keep in your head all of
the considerations that that can be made
when looking into respect
really at your potential for running off
of viable farm operation once you do
acquire land so this kind of lays
everything out on one page for you to
use Family Values is not often
considered people are very excited
usually to start farming to get onto the
land but you really in some cases
committing to a long-term endeavor and
it can be important you know this is
this is a great picture of a happy
family um you know I not sure who the
farmer would be in this picture but I'm
sure the rest of the people would
appreciate being close to the farmer you
know maybe helping out throughout
retirement no that's that's the case I
uh I don't know if Jesse mentioned in a
small bio when we started out but I'm
trying to establish a small fruits farm
and my father has expressed the desire
to work on it throughout his retirement
so I'm gonna be putting my dad to work
hopefully um but it's hard to do that
when you're far away needless to say
there are complicated issues involved in
in figuring out what's best for the
entire family you know not often times
it's not a line necessarily with what's
best for the farm business but it's
definitely good to keep in mind that the
things might be in balance I've heard a
lot from farmers who are established and
say I wish I had settled down closer to
family or in some cases I you know I
wish I hadn't settled this close to my
family yeah I wish I at least they there
at least a half hour away instead of 15
minutes and banging down my door every
day but so I think you guys get the
point there
as I mentioned before considering
ownership costs oftentimes farmers don't
consider every cost that goes into
owning land so this would be specific to
those out in our audience here that are
looking to purchase land and we'll
talking a little bit about how this
applies to if you're leasing land but
for the most part there are several
ownership costs two types of ownership
costs depreciation is when you are when
something is degrading and value over
time and this this applies to
infrastructure on the form this does not
apply to land land as an asset that is
well known to not depreciate you can't
you can't declare in your taxes that
your land is depreciating land generally
stays at its as its present value or
appreciates in value whereas barnes
fencing equipment and other
infrastructure tend to depreciate in
value just over time they're going to
rust and they're going to wear down and
that's considered a cost to whoever is
owning that piece of equipment was ever
zoning that that that piece of
infrastructure it's not necessarily a
tangible cost you're not going to be
paying someone else for for the
depreciation costs but when it comes
time to selling an asset that you own
you're going to be getting a lot less
for it over time as it depreciate
interest commonly amongst agriculture
economists interest is an opportunity
cost so this is this is not really
referring to the cost associated with
paying down a mortgage interest in this
case is referring to the opportunity
cost for owning land in other words if
if one of you or a farm owner purchases
a property for a hundred thousand
dollars you could have used that hundred
thousand dollars at the Wall Street of
the stock market or you could have
invested that hundred thousand dollars
in the CD and you would have been been
getting three percent
interest on that so that's considered an
opportunity cost that you're missing out
when you lock up your capital or your
hundred thousand dollars in a piece of
land repairs and maintenance I've been
living by this statement here everything
works great until it breaks I there
there is definitely truth to it and and
there's there's a definite cost
associated with repairing and
maintaining any equipment or
infrastructure that you have on the farm
and we'll go in a little bit more detail
about that in the following slides taxes
on property now this is one of the most
underestimated ownership costs for
people that are new to acquiring land
they can be taxes on your property can
be significant it's it's a lot easier
these days or in some cases assume you
have good credit or you might have some
collateral ah'd easier to get financing
for the loan to purchase property but
the question is whether or not you can
pay taxes on that property over the long
term and there are ways to assess your
tax hit or your potential tax hit that
is going to be associated with a
particular property and we'll talk about
that in a little bit and lastly
insurance again if you if you're going
to be owning a farm you're going to need
insurance on your property whether that
be casualty insurance or liability
insurance in some cases if you're
inviting the public onto your forum and
those can be considered ownership costs
is everyone still with me is it please
use the smiley face
feel free to use the chat box and enter
your questions as they come up so a
little bit more detail about ownership
costs when you're talking about
infrastructure equipment and buildings
you can use this this equation it's
known as or this formulas known as the
dirty five and that's again going back
to the previous slide you can see the
DDI the are the t in the eye it's this
slide just gives formulas to how to
assess those exact costs so if you're
looking at depreciation you're looking
at if you're looking at the depreciation
on the tractor the original cost might
be $20,000 the salvage value might be
one thousand dollars when it's all said
and done when you're when you're ready
to sell it so you divide that over its
useful life so you're basically taking
the the the original cost of the item
and determining how many years it's
going to take for it to lose all its
value and you're breaking down the costs
over that many years and for interest
you're looking at the original cost
minus salvage value divided by two
you're basically looking at the the
average value of your investment
whatever whatever money you're going to
have the owner is going to have locked
away in the asset you're looking at the
average value of that asset over time
and then you're multiplying that by the
interest rate that's you know that the
going interest rate which which does
fluctuate but again this is an
opportunity cost so you know it would
depend on the period that you're looking
at and I'm assuming you could take an
average interest rate to determine an
actual opportunity interest cost for
repairs generally speaking of the this
the repairs can be one to two percent of
the replacement costs for buildings
now this is based on formulas that
agricultural economists have done all
over the nation they've done surveys of
farmers about how much are you spending
per year on on repairing and maintaining
buildings beyond the average has been
one to two percent how much have has
farmers have been spending per year on
repairing and maintaining machinery
average has been about three to five
percent of costs now obviously your
particular situation might differ and
you know depending on the particular
tractor you're looking at there a
particular building repairs and
maintenance might not be these actual
numbers but these are the averages taxes
for buildings you're looking at the
property tax rate which is going to be
determined at the town level and you're
looking at the assessed value which
again is determined that the town level
but it's yeah I'm not sure how it is in
other states but towns here in Vermont
they have each town has their own
appraisers and Lister's that will come
out to your property and assess the
value you know they'll list it in the
grand list of the town and then they'll
tax you based on the the going rate and
insurance again a general formula you're
looking at the replacement cost for
buildings on the one percent of that
replacement cost is generally what
you're going to be paying in insurance
and for equipment again to ensure that
equipment you're looking at the average
value times about one percent so I know
that's a little bit complicated and
might not be applicable to your
situation right now but it's a good
thing to keep in mind if you do if it
ever does come down to figuring the
actual ownership costs and as will
mention a few minutes landowners if you
look into leased land land owners will
going to want to be assessing their
actual costs for only land so they can
try to determine a cash rental rate to
charge a tenant farmer so they'll be
looking at this formula in detail and
it's good to know what a landlord is
going to be looking at to try to find
some middle ground
doing the number that they determine
from this formula and the number that
you'll be able to handle through your
business or the going market rental rate
and we'll talk about that in a minute or
two getting a little ahead of ourselves
here sorry about oh sorry everyone I
think I hit the wrong key here and went
to the end of the slideshow just bear
with me here so again the dirty five
formula is one way that landlords can
estimate now this is this is relevant to
if you're leasing it's a situation if
you're looking to lease a property
you're trying to determine a price to
pay per year per acre for cash rental on
the land owners are might be using this
dirty five formula to estimate how much
they could charge you as a farmer tenant
and in most cases all of those ownership
costs put together the depreciation
interest repairs taxes and insurance
oftentimes all those costs put together
are going to be way more than a farmer
can actually pay based on their
enterprise plan so if one hundred
percent of these costs cannot be covered
by the farmer what percentage of the
cost can be and that's for you guys to
determine if you are farmer looking to
lease land it is suggested that you
determine what you are actually able to
pay for cash rent so this involves the
careful estimation of what you are going
to be returning from your farm business
per acre and it also involves a careful
estimation of what you need to live what
your what are your family needs and how
much is your family or your or you
yourself spending per month on all of
your living expenses and then you can
determine what you're able to pay for
cash rent aside we've outlined a basic
formula here your neck now this is not
for a cur but you use just generally
speaking for the whole deal your net
returns before your lease payment this
is from your farm business and net
returns being your income after all of
your expense all of your other expenses
are paid such as fertilizer in such as
seed and and whatnot it's going to be
that net return minus the percent that
you need to reinvest into your farm
operation that you plan to reinvest into
your farm operation over time minus your
family needs equals how much is left
over that you could afford to pay in
your total cash lease payment so these
are some some basic business planning
principles that can go into figuring out
how much you can handle for for cash
rent and it it enables you to develop a
middle ground between what you can
handle or my or i should say between
what you might want to pay for for lease
land and between that and what a
landowner might want to charge you and
then number three there is is careful
examination of cash flow so you need to
know when you'll be able to pay a
landlord the lease payment you need to
know when cash is going to be available
in your particular business cycle if
it's you know if you're going to have a
horde of cash in October after you've
you've sold all your produce in
September then you know maybe that's the
time to schedule your lease payment
instead of in in February when there's
when cash flow is next to nothing
again they can't really overemphasize as
a farmer you need to know what you're
able to handle financially and in terms
of purchase it goes the same way are you
able to handle the purchase based on
your off farm income based on the income
that you'll gain from the farm
Enterprise once you do purchase land and
are you able to handle so between that
you're off farm income you're on farm
income and your savings are you able to
handle the down payment on the purchase
of land are you able to handle the
closing costs you are if you have a real
estate agent involved you can be paying
them three percent plus or minus if you
have an attorney involved you might be
paying anywhere from four hundred to a
thousand dollars in closing costs you
know and you have and there's other
costs associated with getting financing
depending on the terms of the loan that
you might be getting to purchase land
need to make sure that you can handle
all of these costs and then and then of
course your monthly mortgage payment
based on your income and can you handle
these ownership costs a lot of times
number two they're the monthly mortgage
payment the banks will make sure that
based on your income you can handle that
that payment based on your cash flow
from off farm income or based on the
farm business they're going to they're
going to be reluctant to extend you
alone unless they know that you can
handle that payment but rarely do banks
make sure that you're going to be able
to handle ownership costs there you know
they a good loan officer will ask you if
you can handle taxes and insurance and
repairs and all the equipment and
maintenance that you have for the farm
so number three is really something up
for you guys to keep an eye on closely
you should be keeping an eye on all
these but number three won't be handed
to you on a silver platter you can
really be need to do some research on
your own
some general business planning
considerations for leasing you can get a
tax deduction based on you on the money
you're paying in cash rental per year
that's why it often makes sense to lease
land you're actually you're paying less
taxes by deducting your your expense of
making your lease payment and again you
have to time your cash flow for your
lease payment schedule that's important
you need to have cash on hand for other
factors that are going to be involved in
your leasing land you're going to be
paying liability insurance in most cases
if you're leasing you're gonna have to
cover minor repairs and regular
maintenance so it's great to know or to
plan beforehand to know that you have
that cash cash on hand and again for
capital improvements this is something
that you would it could be assessed at
the point of considering which
particular improvements that you might
be undertaking at a particular property
you need to know if you're going to be
making that investment that's generally
start-up costs if you're if you're
making a capital improvement you know
it's not considered as a business
expense but if you're going to be making
a significant investment in in a capital
B let's say you're building a greenhouse
in a particular property that you're
leasing or you're adding on to a barn it
pays to know where that money is coming
from and what the strategies that is
going to be for retaining equity and
that infrastructure improvement once it
is made in other words if you're paying
for a twenty-thousand-dollar barn
improvement and if you're leasing that
land what's going to happen when you
when the lease term expires how are you
going to be recouped for your investment
that you've made as the farmer tenant
and lease terms as kathy went over in
the last webinar the terms of your lease
can specify what what is the formula for
determining how
tenant farmer can get repaid for their
investment and what are the terms that
that go along with that so these are
just the 5 CS of credit if you if you do
decide to approach the loan office of
Finance here for credit in order to
purchase a property a conventional loan
officer is going to be evaluating your
case based on these five criteria it
easier to remember the 5 CS of credit
and again this is for most conventional
lenders whether it be the Farm Service
Agency state agricultural credit
corporations or commercial banks they're
going to be looking at your character
capital conditions collateral capacity
now character lenders will be judging
you based on what you know how
professional you are presenting yourself
they're going to be for the most part
trying to get a sense of how well you
know your business if you're looking to
acquire a farm in order to run a
business you need to really know your
business well and so they're going to be
asking you questions about how you
pertaining to how we try to get a gauge
and how well you know your business for
the boat for the most part though
lenders use the objective credit score
to do to as a major measure of your
character lenders don't like to make
character judgments because they you
know they can get a really bad rep for
not extending a loan based on someone's
race or ethnicity or sex or and so on so
lenders do like to use the objective
measure of your credit score when it
comes to judging your character in the
context of whether or not you can handle
alone so I guess the bottom line there
is that if your credit is poor and you
hope to get a loan it's worthwhile to
try to build your credit
and I'm definitely not an expert in
where to go to to to get help with that
I don't know if Cathy have you run into
that at all just general resources where
for that farmers can tap into to help
build their credit back to help build
their credit back if they have bad
credit not not really not any more so
than anybody else here in Vermont we
have a central vermont Community Action
Council various community based economic
development organizations that work with
with people on their taxes they work
with people counseling family budgeting
there are various community based
organizations that that offer free
financial counseling that you could go
to to help build your credit back up I'm
here in Vermont I'm not sure about the
rest of the region here so moving on to
capital lenders are going to need to
know that what's on your balance sheet
they're going to need to know that do
you have assets that exceed the amount
that you're that you are taking out a
loan for are you primary they're going
to be looking at what kind of debt you
have already do you have do you have too
much debt to be taking on more and that
go that ties into capacity are you going
to have the capacity to actually repay a
loan and this is based on your income
streams based on your off-farm income
based on your info on farm income and
whether or not you could afford monthly
loan repayments and sometimes a lot of
the agricultural land lenders will
extend an interest-only loan for the
first couple years if they know that
your business model is not is not such
that it can cover principal and interest
just to start out I know farm
does that across the region and I
recently met with an FSA loan officer
and they do that as well that's
something to inquire into if you don't
have a capacity to repay principal and
interest you can get an interest only
loan that will convert into a regular
term loan or sometimes a balloon payment
based on your capacity to repay the loan
conditions is just referring to what
what are the basic market conditions
that surround the type of business that
you're that you're trying to start you
know does it make sense to grow bananas
in the Northeast if you go to a loan
officer and you want to have a banana
papaya operation are they going to
extend you a loan for that are the
conditions right for that maybe not or
maybe you have a secret that you that no
one knows about yet I think there's a
lot of potential for example to grow
fish in greenhouses here in the
Northeast I'm not sure how crazy I'd
sound if I took that idea to a loan
officer but but I guess if you could
prove that conditions are such that
allow for fish culture and greenhouses
and that you've really done your
research again kind of time back to the
character issue then then you'll get
good marks for the for the conditions
aspect and collateral you you're going
to need to you know most loans for from
conventional lenders are securitized
meaning that you you must put up
collateral to guarantee the loan if you
have to default on a loan the bank has
right to just to liquefy your assets and
use that to repay the loan so they can
be looking at again what what kind of
capital do you have do you already have
own real estate you already own assets
do you already own livestock and what is
saleable what what is the the what are
the the liquidity or replacement cost
for each of the assets that you own or
what are what are the values rather for
each of the assets that you own and and
could they be repossessed and sold in
order for the bank or the lender to
recoup the investment that they've made
a new in the form of a loan
so on to the second part of this webinar
take a 30 second break to stretch
anyone's like to grab a fresh of fresh
air or stretch a little bit now's the
time then there was a question earlier
I'm just going to get back to that just
about when you were talking about the
percent reinvested into the farm being
part of the calculation for what you can
afford wondering if that should just be
part of the general farm budget so that
your net returns would have already
accounted for that that was always back
I don't know if you can address that or
would that you know investment actually
be um something that the landowner would
be you know deducting fearless because
you're you know investing in improving
their land or their infrastructure for
that matter
I'm sorry Jessie could you rephrase that
question sure cuff is a little lengthy
but um if you scroll back in the chat
box there was a question from Susan
Peters about the percent reinvested into
the farm operations you were saying that
that should be subtracted when people
are trying to figure out how much they
can afford to pay in the lease and it
looks like Susan was just wondering
shouldn't that you know reinvestment
into the farm already to be part of your
farm budget and already included so that
your net returns would reflect that I
think she was looking questioning why
that wasn't already you know
incorporated when you're figuring out
your net returns from the farm yeah it's
it's the same general concept they your
your net your net income from your farm
operation is going to be revenues minus
expenses so that's the only reason why I
separated those to the the amount the
the money that you're going to take
after all expenses are paid and reinvest
into your farm operation is not usually
considered an expense that's the only
reason I I I separated it out it's it's
good it's great for farmers to think
about income reinvested into their farm
operation as an actual expense and have
a regular habit of reinvesting in come
into their farm business but it's you
know it's generally perceived as
something that happens after you've
figured for your fixed and operating
expenses of the farm business so it's
right so this is beyond just you know
maintenance and doing what you need to
do to get your your crop to market this
is reinvestment that that's going to
improve improve the land or
infrastructure so and I guess the
question is when the landowners somehow
be responsible for that or accounting
for that if you're actually improving
their property
sure if if you are actually improving
their property than you then it's
definitely not a cost so it would be
factored into into that kind of equation
a little bit differently if you can
somehow value of the improvement that
you're making you can definitely deduct
that from a cash rental payment that
you're negotiating Cassie can I just
comment on that I think it depends on
the nature of the agreement between the
landlord and the tenant if you're making
an improvement that the landlord is not
willing to accept a shared cost or the
residual value of it then it would be
your expense and appreciated or whatever
and I'm not a business person but in
terms of the nature of the relationship
between the landlord and the tenant that
would be true on the other hand as
landlord might be willing to either
share in the cost of it for a sign that
your cost as Ben was saying it take that
into consideration when the lease fee is
being calculated so it wouldn't be
automatically one way or the other I
don't think okay I'm signing off
yeah and thanks Cathy and these these
formulas that we're using in these
methods that can be used to determine a
cash rental rate or not are not only set
in stone they're really just references
for for both landowners and farmers to
use two reference points to use in the
negotiation process of determining a
fair rental rate it really depends on
the priorities of both the landowner and
the farmer and the needs of both the
farmer in the landowner to determine an
actual working cash rental rate and we
we went over this in the last webinar
I'm not sure if we want to take time to
go through that again the various ways
to determine a cash rental rate I know
it's a popular question so if we if
anyone wants to speak up if they'd like
to go over that again please let me know
or else we'll just go through the next
set of slides
and I'm just scrolling through the chat
box here until I haven't just catch up
here for another minute dance break good
I'm glad someone was dancing and we
definitely can get copies of the slides
is that right Jessie you want to address
that question will you be sending out a
follow-up email to everyone here for a
link to the recording of this
presentation or I'm not sure if you send
out the actual PowerPoint slides to
participants okay so proper so when
you're assessing a particular let's say
you have gone through all the
preparedness concepts and you're you're
ready to really home in and look at
particular parcels of land whether
you're leasing whether you plan to
purchase or whether you plan to get onto
the land in any of the other ways that
Kathy mentioned in the last webinar so
there are basic things to look at you
want to be looking at natural features
of the land and you can really get into
depth into and some science into looking
at the natural features that exist it's
really a fascinating discipline you want
to take a close look at whatever
infrastructure exists you want to take a
close look at whatever Barnes exists or
whatever fencing exists or whatever
equipment that might be available to you
to assess what needs to go into that
what what kind of repairs and
maintenance what kind of major overhauls
need to go into that on what are the
costs you know we talked about this
already what are the costs they're going
to be associated with owning or or using
that piece of equipment or
infrastructure the financial
considerations we'll talk a little bit
more about taxes and how to assess taxes
on a particular property where to go to
do that and some of the other
considerations involved in that and
we'll also talk about community and
surroundings
so as you probably all know there are
lots of natural variations in in farm in
farmland and land in general it these
are just some of them on the list soil
is is a huge one and we'll talk about
that how you can assess soils will go on
a little web torus is that if that works
for you guys in a minute here topography
microclimates is often underestimated
what's what are what are the different
hardiness zones this ties into climate
you need to know what what hardiness
zone you're looking in what what if you
if you plan on doing vegetables or fruit
trees or other crops what what hardiness
zones can they be grown in but within
each RT is known there's going to be
micro climates are you on a south-facing
slope that's going to that's going to
warm up first in the spring if you're
going fruit trees that might have
implications for frost for having your
flowers and fruit cheese be susceptible
to frost bite because everything thaws
out on the south-facing hillside first
but then you get one or two freak
freezes and then all your flowers are
gone you know you really want to look at
the topography and how they tie into
micro climates water is huge what how
you know if water if water does not
exist it maybe not might not be a parcel
that's worth looking at or at least if
it does not exist what are the costs
that that you might have to take on in
drilling a well or in gaining asset
access to water from other sources
there's a lot that can be done with
spring development and I've gotten this
question a lot lately a a piece of
online can have a sheep on the hillside
and that can be your water source but
you do need to assess what what needs to
be done to that is it feasible to
develop a spring out of that water
source can you dig a trench on the on
the hillside there and funnel more water
into a reservoir Natural Resource
Conservation Service is an excellent
resource
they have plans and schematics for how
you can go about doing that and you
might be able to get you might be able
to consult with an NRCS specialists in
your state or your County who might be
able to come out to the to the farm that
you're looking at and assess how water
resources can be conserved how flow of
spring can be Springs there can be
increased how you might be able to tap
into river resources and you know enable
yourself to be independent from town or
village water and and utilize the water
that exists on site vegetation a big
question or a common question is is it
is it feasible to clear forests you know
we have we have really cheap forest land
that that's evelio we this this land is
being sold for next to nothing and if we
buy that land we can just clear the
forest and that I am NOT a forester I'm
not a logger so the the actual costs
associated with clearing forests the
actual impacts of clearing forests would
depend on what's there to begin with but
generally speaking I tell people that
it's often not cost-effective to clear
forests that exists it's the the money
that you're going to save in the
purchase price of land is not going to
surpass what you're going to spend in
clearing for us in the environmental
degradation that's going to ensue from
you clearing a particular piece of
property and then again it depends on
your timeline if your look if you're
doing if you're talking about a
short-term lease it's often yeah I
haven't haven't come across any cases
where it's really worth it to clear for
us to enable cropping but if you do have
a longer term horizon it might be
feasible to do that little by little
more about soils
can you guys see my arrow here and maybe
I can use this thing here you can see my
little wand here you are looking at soil
profiles we're looking what exists
underneath the surface of the soil
you're going to be if you're going out
to assess particular property you me
walk in the land and oh no slide or one
visible hmm is anyone that that can see
my wand here can anyone else see my wand
hey Ben to use that you actually need to
click it'll put a there you go a dot and
that's going to move over time you click
to a new spot okay well that's the
surface of the soil we're looking at and
this is the the the depth of the soil
this is about we're looking at about two
feet underneath the surface right here
at that dot maybe about three feet right
underneath there and obviously if you're
standing right here you might not be
able to to understand what exists right
here I do suggest that if you're if
you're seriously considering owning or
leasing a piece of property that you
obtain permission from the owner before
you before you start probing into soil
but you do take the time and energy to
probe down into the soil whether that be
digging a small ditch with this shovel
whether that be using some of the tools
they're shown here this is a small two
foot soil probe that can be used for
taking tiny little corium about the size
of your your thumb you can get small
soil cores if you if you probe down
about a foot or two this is a bucket
auger
and this can be used for probing down
about 5 or 6 feet depending on the the
length of the handle here are and a lot
of times University land-grant
universities have these NRCS soil
scientists have these they might be able
to come out to your site it costs about
one hundred fifty dollars two to three
hundred dollars this this bucket augers
is a lot more expensive than this this
piece of equipment here is about thirty
dollars that can be used and of course a
garden shovel works but you want to
obtain permission to be able to look at
the soils that you might be dealing with
this soil here is going to have
tremendously different implications
using the soil than this would this this
year is is known as into Saul it's a
very young soil it's extremely nutrient
deficient it's extremely sandy it might
be great for some uses if you can amend
enough nutrients but because it is well
drained this soil on the other hand is
is a I think it's a picture from the
Midwest the breadbasket region where
it's a tremendously vertel soil this is
probably what you're going to be seeing
more in the northeast of New England
areas it's a little bit younger of a
soil it's going to be a probably a lot
more sandy than you then you'd find out
in the Midwest but oftentimes you do
find this soil on the right side is is a
visit you can see the cracks down the
middle here is due to the high clay
content and you know this is gonna be a
tremendous the Clay's of tremendously
heavy soil that's going to be very hard
to work especially in the spring so it
really pays to dig down from the surface
get to feel the soils that you'd be
working with get to know them a little
better and don't let your soils be a
secret um so let's talk a little bit
more about assessing soils you can use
the online web soil survey as a tool for
assessing site soils
and we'll try to launch a little web
tour here and see if this works bear
with me for a second here okay so please
indicate with the smiley faces as you
can see this page the usda nrcs you see
it Jessica so so great you guys can see
this this is a tremendously useful tool
that's offered by united states
department of agriculture and natural
resource conservation service and what
the Natural Resource Conservation
Service has done all over the nation is
that they've surveyed soils I'm sorry
that's some of you can't see this
hopefully we can get that resolved sweet
so they've surveyed soils all over the
nation they did this back in the 60s
when there's a big effort isn't as a
civilian conservation corps or some big
federal program that enabled soil
scientists to go out all over the nation
and catalog soils and since then the the
surveys have gotten a more detailed and
and they become digitized which is a
great advantage for us online users you
can go into into the web soil survey the
click on this screen button here um
and try this so I I've tried this before
of a webinar it's tough to to go through
this but you can click on the state
where your way you're in you can use the
navigation tools over on the left to
enter your address and what you do first
is you enter your address your area of
interest which means you're basically
I'm sorry I can't display this over the
webinar but you're basically the once
you type in an address or location will
give you an aerial map and you can draw
a rectangle using this first screen here
you can draw a rectangle or a shape over
the area where you're looking to assess
as the property you're interested in and
then within that rectangle it will
divide up the different soil types and
you can then investigate the soil types
that exist there you can click on the
tabs here you can click on the soil map
and again i'm sorry i can't do that but
you can you can click on the soil data
explorer to learn a lot more about the
potential for the particular soils that
are on site there if you know the series
name let me try to launch another web
tour here
for the sake of time I'm not going to
get into the nitty-gritty of soil series
but basically if you could every soil
series has an every soil type down to
the most detailed classification has a
series name associated with it you know
and their conventional names based on
geography it might be the state bird or
something like that is the name of the
soil it might be the town name where the
soils predominantly exist but once you
have that soil series name you can enter
it you can do and you go to the nrcs
Natural Resource Conservation Service
website and you you can do a search
there for for for soils series
description and you can enter in the
soil series name and get a full
description of the soil and how it acts
what kind of drainage it has what kind
of crops grow there in the native
habitat and all kinds of other other
factors you know how deep the soil is to
bedrock into water table what kind of
soil is it is a sandy soil is a clay
soils are predominated by silt you can
really learn a ton from knowing what
soil series exists in the particular
parcels that you're interested and again
you can do some detailed probing and
again have permission before you do this
and try to cover up the holes that
you've dug for building purposes if you
are looking to lease or own land and you
and you know that you might need
buildings most states have permitting
requirements for erecting buildings for
for making the for building dwellings
especially and the permits usually
relate to what kind of septic systems
what kind of wastewater disposal systems
are going to need to be installed
on-site according to the regulations
that each state has so in Vermont here
it's the Department of Environmental
Conservation wastewater management
division that handles those permanent
regulations and there's you know it's in
all of these states
it's these are laws that have been
passed so this is public information you
can have dig into the law that was
passed related to the requirements that
are needed to install a septic system
and you can say okay if I want to put a
one bedroom house I'm going to need to
build this size septic system that's all
that's all been written into law at one
time or another and then the states have
various permitting processes to in order
to for the state to give the go-ahead
for you to build or not but it really
all depends on soils so the the
particular soils that exists on site are
going to determine the potential for
building potential for for installing a
septic system or a potable water supply
system so oftentimes if you're looking
to purchase if you're set to purchase
land the before you actually sign a
contractor you'll sign the purchase and
sales agreement which is a contract that
says you're going to purchase the
property based on the contingency that
the site passes a percolation test based
on the soils will exist there so that's
you know that's often a condition that
will exist within your purchase contract
and it's generally not wise to to
purchase a property if you don't know
that it's going to percolate that it's
going to pass these certain tests that
are going to allow you for building some
cases you might not care at all you
might not have you might not really care
about building or the potential do so in
that case this does not apply there are
other ways to assess various natural
features or properties in Vermont we
have a service that's it's an online
service that's run by the agency of
natural resources I'm not sure if other
states have this kind of service but you
you're able to get online and search
through all of these if you have a
particular property in mind you're
you're able to build through all of
these variables and learn more about
your particular property again there be
an aerial map associated with it with
your search and you can have different
layers and determine whether or not
storm
water permits are needed if the areas
have been demarcated as wildlife habitat
or not if there's sensitive wetlands
there if there's legal permits that have
been issued according to environmental
uses all kinds of things can be learned
about properties by using that service
again you want to assess the quality of
infrastructure that you're going to be
dealing with well whether how much are
you going to be how much do you estimate
putting into repairing and maintaining
all the equipment that you're about to
acquire or make use of or all the
buildings that you're about to inhabit
or use as storage sheds what what are
you going to have to do what's what are
you going to have to build their what
kind of roof are you going to have to
repair and you know what's what are the
repairs and manage and how can they be
distinguished from the major overhauls
and upgrades that need to happen this is
important especially if you're
developing a lease agreement to agree
with with the landowner what is
considered a major overhaul versus a
routine maintenance of most commonly the
farmer tenant is expected to handle
route between and cover the cost of
routine maintenance and repairs whereas
if it's a major overhaul that's going to
considerably alter the value of an asset
if it's a major repair you're replacing
an engine and a tractor or something
that's going to really increase the
value of that tractor by three thousand
dollars or it's it's it's obviously a
major overhaul the landowners usually
are expected to cover that cost unless
you have a specific agreement otherwise
so a lot of times it's obvious but the
bottom line is that a lot of times it's
not and it's really worthwhile to have a
conversation about what is maintenance
what what needs to be repaired and what
needs to be overhauled in a major way
and again there there are some
permitting issues involved in major
construction if you are building a road
for instance to access a particular
property you might need to look into the
town permitting regulations there might
be state permits involved in disturbing
a certain amount of soil in Vermont for
example if you disturb more than one
acre of soil on with the development you
need a special permit you need an act
250 you need to go through and an act
250 permit with sediment and erosion
control plans in place so back to the
tax issue and this might sound
repetitive but again it's extremely
important to assess what are the taxes
you be paying on a particular parcel and
this speaks to if you're purchasing a
little bit more than if you are leasing
again going back a few slides you get
even get a tax deduction if you're
leasing land if you're if you own land
you're going to be paying a lot of Texas
and again a vermont-based example there
is a special program here that allows
farmers in certain cases to get a
significant tax benefit if they are
actively farming here in Vermont it's
called the Vermont use value appraisal
program and you can get information
about that at the Vermont State
Department of taxes as you can get
information at the various State
Department of taxes wherever you're from
or wherever you're you're looking at
properties and at the department of
taxes you'll find eligibility
requirements for getting into these tax
benefit programs for example in Vermont
if you're going to enroll agricultural
land that land has to be producing two
thousand dollars worth of income for
with regard sorry gross revenue for the
farmer per year once once the farmer on
that land is making more than two
thousand dollars a year from
agricultural products the land can be
enrolled in the tax benefit program that
means the town is not going to be able
to assess that land at fair market value
for taxes here land is often
test it about ten to twenty percent a
fair market value for tax purposes
that's you know it's a significant
savings to get into these tax benefit
programs for forest land another example
here in Vermont you need more than 25
acres of continued contiguous forest
land in order for you to enroll that
land in the tax benefit program farm
buildings can be a step assessed at zero
percent tax value it again it all
depends on the particular program where
you reside or where you're looking and
there is potential for housing for farm
employees to be taxed at zero percent
base in other words housing for our
employees is not text if it's enrolled
in the tax benefit program and this this
is for example here and promote this is
special to are specific to where there's
a and employee relationship this would
not apply for a tenant for a farmer
who's renting a house on a piece of
farmland if you're renting a house that
and you're not an employee of a farm you
know that that house is going to still
be taxed at normal fair market value but
again that's a Vermont specific example
I don't know if caffeine olds any more
about the other states programs or if
there any if there's any major
differences to what I just mentioned
Kathy are you available
ok
I'll come back to that let's see the
town office is a wealth of information
if you're talking about taxes you can
get at at the town you can get the exact
map and the exact acreage that the
town's going off of for you know what
what what the acreage is of the
particular parcel that they're assessing
it's not necessarily the actual acreage
that exists on a particular parcel for
actual acreage you're going to need to
have a professional soil or a
professional survey done of the land but
oftentimes the towns will have estimates
of acres that are very very close to
those at those surveyed measurements you
know oftentimes there was a survey that
was done 50 years ago or a hundred years
ago so the the amount of acreage at the
town is taxing might be plus or minus
but you can get all that information at
the town office you can get aerial maps
of the properties that you're looking at
that often helps if you're walking
properties to understand what kind of
patches of pasture exists here and what
kind of patches of forest exist there
and where are the exact of the actual
borders you can get current title
information you know this is important
if you you know you need to know that
the person you're dealing with actually
owns the land it's not you're not
dealing with the uncle or something and
someone comes home from Florida and all
of a sudden you're leasing their land
and they don't know about it at the town
office you can ascertain that the person
who you're dealing with actually has
title to the land and this is something
that attorneys will access if they're
doing a title search on to make sure
there aren't any other encumbrances on
the land they'll go through all the town
records and really look closely at at
this item zoning regulations you can get
that information at the town in a lot of
states there is a right to farm law
where agriculture is not zoned against
in other words
they're at least in Vermont so I'm sorry
in Vermont there there isn't any zoning
regulations that would preclude anyone
from farming in any particular location
everyone has a right to farm assuming
that you're not posing a hazard to
public health but there are nuisance
laws that can go into effect that that
farmer should should be aware of in
other words even though there's no
regulation to to prohibit anyone from
farming if the farmer comes in two moves
into an area and is new there and starts
running an operation that it is
obviously detracting from other
bordering properties owners ability to
enjoy the use of their land then the
farmer can fall victim to a nuisance
lawsuit so just address this question
here I've heard many tales of issues
with easements and grandfather roads
crossing farmland and how to address
this area this is this is another
crucial bit of information that can be
accessed at the town office you
definitely need to know if there's any
easements whatsoever on a particular
property and you can't you know you
can't really if there is an easement on
a particular property that's a legal
right for another on't for another
person to you know access to you if
there if it's an easement for a road
there that person is gonna have legal
ability to use that road no matter what
if it's a power company they're going to
have the legal right to own the land
that the power lines go through even if
even though they're running through your
land so I guess the only way to address
this area is to have knowledge of the
particular
terms that are associated with that
easement to know exactly how many feet
within either side of the power pole for
example are covered within that easement
and to understand who owns the easement
and what attitude they're going to have
about you acquiring the rest of the
property that surrounds that that area
that's applicable to the easement so did
that answer your question Nate
comparable sales data this is a way to
determine the fair market value of a
particular property this kind of
information I've been told is available
at the town offices I'm not I haven't
ever gone to the towns and asked them to
see records of recent sales I'm not sure
how far back they keep records this
might be different from town to town but
essentially real estate agents when they
go to appraise a particular property
this is the kind of they're going to the
town records or the state records and
they're they're accessing this kind of
data to to determine a fair market value
for a particular property they're basing
that fair market value on the sales the
sale prices of comparable properties in
the area and I've been told that this is
something you can do on your own
although I'm not sure again it would
probably depend on from town to town
what kind of data is available and how
it's available but this is essentially
something that a real estate agent would
do which is another not so bad idea if
you are looking to purchase a piece of
property to get a real estate agent of
yours on board to represent you so they
can they're going to be the experts at
determining the fair price to pay for a
particular property it's hard to go in
alone I know the tendency is to be
reluctant to pay three percent in a
commission just to have a real estate
agent help you through some listings
that you could access on your own but
sometimes it pays especially if the real
estate agent can really confirm the the
fair price that could that can be paid
for particular property that may might
be a lot less than you would ordinarily
pay if you were trying to determine that
fair market value on your own
so are there any other questions before
I move on are there any that I have not
addressed yeah I think we're going to be
wrapping up in about 10 minutes here 830
is our cutoff time I appreciate everyone
bearing with us up to now I hope that
you're getting something out of this ah
this is a great thing to not be shy
about if you're trying to assess the
particular property it's a don't be shy
to talk with neighbors and and and
people who have been who know the land
would prove and hunting on a particular
property for for ages throughout
generations we really know the ins and
outs on how a property acts over time
you know I throughout the seasons all
the people who live right around your
neighbors there or people with that kind
of local knowledge exist and you know
it's really a great thing to be able to
talk with him if they're willing so just
to jump back here a little bit can tax
records Dave to be used to assess
potential value of a property they could
if you know the tax rate for a
particular town at least the town
Lister's are going to have the value of
a property that they have assessed there
that you know I might it's probably
easier in other words to go directly to
the town lister and figure out what is
the value of the land that they're
basing the tax on because they have
assessed the property and they have
assessed the fair market value of the
property at some time or another it
might have been seven years ago it might
have been just last year that's
something you need to ask so in other
words the value that the real estate
sisters at the town level and work for
the town office of have appraised might
not be the actual fair market value of
the land the land owner might be able to
get a lot more for that right now based
on the market conditions or orb or it
might be even let you know less value
depending on the situation but at least
you can use that that basic list value
that the the appraisers at the town
level that have used and if you're savvy
you can use the tax form those two to
arrive at that figure up as well there
are resources for help in filing for
current you status in Vermont at least
it's the county foresters who are that
resource the county foresters job is to
administer and check up on all of the
current use management plans so when you
when someone doesn't roll into a tax
benefit program they usually submit a
management plan that states how they're
going to manage the forest for
productivity and how are they you know
what they're doing to AG land and so on
and here in Vermont it's the county
foresters that that have files on all
the properties and manage that
information from time to time they'll
actually visit properties are checked up
on whether management plans are being
enforced so the county foresters can
really walk you through what it takes to
enroll in current use they might be able
to help you figuring out what figure out
whether or not you're eligible and then
that the county foresters will refer you
to consulting foresters and these are
consulting land use planners they're you
know they're they're not always just
foresters but they have experience in
helping people enroll in the current use
plans the Vermont woodlands Association
has certified Forester consultants you
know most towns have someone or most
areas have someone that's experienced in
consulting with private landowners on
whether or not they're eligible for
current use I'm assuming the same case
in other states yeah the main goal of
these tax benefit programs is to keep
the land open and productive so there is
if it's not private consulting foresters
it's going to be some other agricultural
service provider organization that can
assist you in support you as a landowner
whose will it is to keep the land open
and productive you know that might be a
state agency of Agriculture it might be
a cooperative extension service you know
I can definitely help anyone that's
something that I do I I know the the
basic ins and outs of the Vermont
current use burger and I consult with
with farmers and landowners I'd be happy
to talk with anyone hear about that at
any time so again back to community
don't don't be afraid to partner are
sorry don't be afraid to talk with
current tenants but at the same time be
sensitive that they are not always
obligated to share information with you
you have to be sensitive to the fact
that if you're looking to lease land if
there's a current tenant there already
that tenant might not know that the
landowner wants to lease land to you you
know and maybe not least as much land to
the current tenant as as before you have
to be sensitive to that fact when you
approach current tenants and and you
know it's just approach the matter was
some respect and humility um you know
and I think it's always good to ask the
landowner or the tenants if it would be
okay to to access records or talk with
them from time to time so we're running
out of time here I'll just sift through
this quickly here's another resource
that's available at UVM extensions new
farmer project this is going through
various considerations this is a
checklist that's similar to the one that
we brought up earlier that's in holding
ground it goes through all detailed
considerations and assessing properties
here are some additional resources these
are organizations you can go to if you
have any other questions about any of
the topics that were covered in either
of these two webinars
um this is specific to Vermont intervale
center here is in chittenden county then
for good has an associate Mike ghia who
works at a wyndham county in vermont
he's all over the state here but land
for good is generally a new
england-based organization Cathy you
maybe you can speak to a little bit more
about what you guys offer because I have
you guys also on this last slide here
again land for good is a tremendous
resource they're based in the New
England states no Cathy if you work
throughout New York as well but
northeast beginning farmers project is
out of Cornell University Extension
they're a great resource to go to to
learn more about land access and tenure
issues international farm transition
Network has lists as organizations that
do listing and linking programs all over
the nation and then again we're
available here at UVM extension and
there's there's some other educational
resources available in the land access
tool shed at this URL here at UVM
extensions new farmer project website
official and thank you yeah land for
good does have a land here program which
does focus on helping seekers we have
offer individual consulting lease
drafting we helped non-farming
landowners recruits beginning farmers so
for I mean farm speakers so that helps
on the other end we do have a couple of
online tools lease templates we think
tutorial a full course on land
acquisition will be online and we serve
to six New England states we do a teeny
bit of work in New York but we're really
focusing on building our partnerships in
in New England
Thanks well thanks Cathy wood that will
journeyer Jesse had some more yeah I
just wanted to say thank you so much Ben
and Kathy for joining us this evening
and for all of you who participated I do
want to ask you and before you go on to
other things if you can take a minute
and fill out this survey I'm going to
send you the link right now we do really
appreciate feedback on these webinars
and also other things that you might be
interested in seeing webinars on and
that kind of thing so you can follow
that link it's just super quick survey
and we'd love your input so thanks
everyone thanks Cathy and Ben and we
will be sending you some follow-up
information if you put your email in the
chat box if you haven't done that
already go ahead and put your email in
there we'll send you a link to the
recording of this presentation also
where the PDF of the presentation is and
that kind of thing all right folks
thanks so much
you